un peu de riz fille pour les habitants
de la goutte à rians talent avec
l'entrée en vigueur d'un cessez-le-feu
de cinq heures décrétée par le président
russe vladimir poutine
les bombardements incessants des deux
dernières semaines par le régime syrien
et ses alliés se sont tues mais la pause
n'a pas duré en pleine trêve les tirs
d'artillerie résonnaient toujours dans
la banlieue de damas à siéger
alors qu'on sait changer le blâme de
part et d'autre pour sept plus récentes
violations un corridor mis en place par
le régime de bachar al assad pour
évacuer la population civile est resté
désert depuis 2013 les quelques 400
mille habitants de la goutte à rians
talent souffre de pénuries de nourriture
de médicaments et de denrées de base en
ou 2013 c'est là que s'est déroulée la
première attaque menée à l'aide de gaz
sarin qui sera finalement resté sans
réponse militaire de la communauté
internationale
aujourd'hui les habitants ont malgré
tout boudé le passage vers l'extérieur
les habitants de la goutte à rians
talent refuse de quitter la région et
refuse cette décision dit mohammed
c'est quoi cette trêve de quelques
heures donc après 14 heures il va y
avoir des raids aériens et encore plus
de dégâts de morts et 202 man tilt la
russie demande it à bourg hassan
auparavant elle a annoncé une trêve à
alep et des femmes et des gens étaient
arrêtés
elle a annoncé une trêve ici dans la
gutta mais malgré cela un bombardement
et lui il y à quelques instants dit il
nous ne serons pas la prochaine à l'aip
voilà ce que répètent les habitants
activistes et combattants dans les
conversations à distance que nous avons
eu au cours des dernières semaines
plutôt mourir a siégé de 2012 à 2016 un
cessez-le-feu à l'epp avait donné lieu à
une évacuation massive de la population
dans la partie contrôlée par les
rebelles
prélude à une invasion terrestre qui a
permis au régime de reprendre l'ensemble
du territoire isolé la population de la
goutte orientale se tourner vers les
réseaux sociaux
mohamed najib un adolescent de la douma
à frapper les consciences bien au-delà
des limites de l'enclavé oui les
prisonniers
ils reprochent à la communauté
internationale son silence et son
immobilisme tout aussi meurtriers que
les bombes et les mortiers de damas
accuse-t-il
la russie l'iran et la syrie affirme que
la gutta est entre les mains de
terroristes et donc une cible légitime
malgré la résolution du conseil de
sécurité appelant à une trève de 30
jours pourtant astana et à genève
quelques reprises l'an passé ils se sont
assis à la table des négociations avec
les forces qui la contrôlent deux
principaux groupes islamistes ont la
mainmise sur la butte à des chats
l'islam et ce quelque dix mille
combattants et file à cal rahman qui
compte 9000 hommes
les deux factions sont populaires au
sein de la population locale
même si on leur reproche aussi de se
faire des profits avec le marché noir et
le peu d aide humanitaire qui est
parvenu dans la goutte a été dernier la
goutte à rians talent avait été désignée
comme zone de désescalade par la russie
et l'iran les deux amis militaires de la
syrie ainsi que la turquie qui soutient
l'opposition
un accord qui ne vaut rien de plus que
le papier sur lequel il a été rédigé la
communauté internationale s'indigne sans
conséquence
il ne faut pas prétendre qu'il s'agit
d'une guerre c'est un massacre accusait
le président de human rights watch
kenneth roth ici le massacre est
possible croit-il
c'est la faute de la russie ici
marie-eve bédard radio-canada beyrouth
[Applaudissements]